The boat travels 576 miles in either direction. Great work if you found this.
We can find this answer by plugging in the value of x which is 84 and take each
of these expressions. Either expression will give us the correct answer, so
let's make sure. If we take the expression for distance for upstream and
replace the value of x with 84, we see that the answer is 576. The same would
be true for downstream. We replace x with 84 to get 504 plus 72 which equals
576. This should make sense that the distances are equal. The boat travel
downstream first and then it went back the same distance to return. So, this
supports our reasoning for how we solve the equation and we know the boat
traveled 576 miles in each direction.